Musik Ja, wir haben heute, wir wollten heute aufnehmen, aber dann habe ich vor unserem Aufnahmestudio ein einsames, verirrtes Reh gesehen, das wild durch den Regen geschwommen ist.
Auf der Strasse.
Und dann dachte ich mir, das können wir nicht alleine lassen und haben sie direkt eingeladen. Herzlich willkommen bei uns, wie heisst du noch gleich?
Uh, Katja, da Gerz.
So, du musst ein bisschen näher ans Mikrofon gehen.
Ach so, hier, hier auch.
So dass man dein Gesicht nicht mehr sieht, ein bisschen vom Kopf zuum zu sein. Das ist die Idee, dass wir… Das ist alles verstecken. Katjana Gerz ist da. Ein Name, der wahrscheinlich viele Emotionen bei euch auslöst. Erst mal Verwirrung, Bewunderung, Ekelheit. Aber auch gleich Freude, auch so ein bisschen, was ist das, was kommt da jetzt gerade auf uns zu? Katjana ist auch so ein ausgedachter Name. Habe ich gehört in deinem Stand-up. Wow! Oh, Segway, Segway! Ja, so langsam fangen wir jetzt an, dich durch so Improvisationsstücke vorzustellen. Du machst ein Stand-up und du hast auch gesagt, dass Katjana ausgedacht ist. Eine Mischung aus Katja und Tatjana. Du kannst mein Set, ey! Ja, ich mach deine Bits jetzt ja einfach. Das meinst du, woher die ganzen Gags hatte in den letzten acht Folgen. Aber ich hab sie auch schon geklaut, also wird sie jetzt so offen sich klauen. Okay, das ist ärgerlich. Aber das ist schon crazy, dass Leute sich Namen ausdenken, ne? Ja, ja. Aber meine Eltern, die haben ja auch krasse Namen, weil also die haben sich ja kennengelernt in so einer Sekte in Indien irgendwo. Und der Guru hat meinem Vater den Namen Purathan gegeben und meine Mutter heisst Abinabo. Also er he? Abinabo. Abinabo und Katjana. Und mein Bruder heisst George. Paul. Vielleicht so einfach aufgegeben, ja George. So, an acid trip ist vorbei. Wir haben die ganze Kreativität unseres Lebens verbraten, George. Aber ist es nicht ... Also es tut mir leid für die Leute, die Katja heissen, weil, gut, deine Eltern wollten sich anscheinend zwischen Katja und Tatjana nicht entscheiden und haben aber nur das K von Katja genommen eigentlich. Ja. Das ist Katjana. Also im Endeffekt ist Tatjana fast komplett ... Man hätte auch Tatja sagen können. Ja. Oder Tanja. Tanja ist eigentlich die Kombination aus Tatjana und Anja. Aber wisst ihr, ich wurde in Hamburg geboren, ja, und damals, weil hier in Deutschland ist es ja so, du hast ja, in Amerika kannst du ja dein Kind Apple nennen oder was weiss ich, kannst ja alles machen. Und in Deutschland gibt es ein Buch und der Name war nicht im Buch und die haben zuerst gesagt, nee, geht nicht, geht nicht. Moment, es gibt ein Buch, in dem alle Namen drinstehen, die man haben darf? Ja, in Deutschland, also dein Name muss im Buch sein. Das ist aber seltsam. Ja. Ist das ein grosses Buch oder ist das nur ein kleines Reglerbeschäft drin? Da steht nur ein ganz dünnes Buch. Es ist so dünn wie die deutsche Comic. Da wollen wir echt mit dir drüber sprechen. Also du hast ja diesen krassen Blick zwischen den Welten, hängst du die ganze Zeit in deinem Leben, zwischen Amerika, Funland, hey wir hauen mega Gags raus, bei uns kommen die geilen Comedians her. Und dem Holocaustland. Und dem Holocaustland, yay, mit Mario Barth als Speerspitze der deutschen Comedy. Wie fühlst du dich dazwischen hin und her gerissen? Ähm, gut. Cool, das war Katja, war gern. Ansonsten, was ist eigentlich in der Politik los, Leute? Crazy! Crazy! Ne, ich sag auch immer, ich hab so zwei Seiten, die eine Seite ist so frei, aber dumm, und die andere ist kultiviert, aber innen drin tot. Aber ne, es ist so, ich finde immer, wenn ich in Deutschland bin, fühle ich mich sehr amerikanisch, und wenn ich in Amerika bin, bin ich immer die Deutsche. Wie kommt das denn überhaupt, dass du diese gespaltene Persönlichkeit hast, dass du in zwei Ländern gleichzeitig lebst? Weil mein Vater Deutscher ist, meine Mutter Amerikanerin. Und dann war immer so, wir sind in Deutschland geboren, dann hatte meine Mutter Heimweh, sind wir nach Amerika, dann hat mein Vater Heimweh, dann sind wir wieder zurück, dann hatte ich irgendwie Heimweh, dann bin ich dahin. George Heimweh, Pakistan aus irgendeinem Grund. George, genau, he is totally lost, das Haarmodel. Jetzt ist er aber eier. Was macht George, erzähl mir mehr von George. Macht er Haarmodel? Nee, war für eine ganz lange Zeit Haarmodel. Haarmodel? Also so wie Haarmilch oder was? Nee, der hat... Ja! Geh einfach kurz raus. Jack, ein haltbares Model. Ich klatsche nicht, George. Aber Haarmodel, weil er sehr lange, schöne Haare hatte oder weil er sehr kurze, oder war es so ein Vorherbild, irgendwie Schuppenflechte? Er ist immer das Vorherbild. Er ist immer das Vorherbild. Es war sehr gemein, aber... Professionelles Vorherbild. Aber was heißt Haarmodel? Genau, der hat eine Agentur, so hässlich. Ne, der hat so Laufsteaks, äh, Lauf... Ähm, hier so richtig, so immer näher so richtig. Sehr professionell, dass so während jemand spricht das Mikrokurs wegreißt, dann wieder anders hinstimmst. Ich habe damit gerechnet, dass sie mehr in meine Richtung spricht, ich als Alternarzisst. Jetzt steht ein Besen vor ihr. Du hast das Mikro weggenommen, jetzt steht ein Besen vor ihr. Also bitte ein bisschen darauf achten, dass du ein bisschen näher kommst. Ich habe Angst, dass sie unsere Zuhörer nicht hören. Okay, der ist H-Model, wie kam es dazu? Ich weiss es gar nicht, der hatte eine Freundin, die war irgendwie ein richtiger Model.Model. Die war eine richtige Model und die Schublade konnte nicht rein und dann hatte er aber schöne Haare und dann haben die auch, dem war es egal, wenn sie die halt lila gefärbt haben und so. Und dann ist er halt so Laufsteg, richtig runtergelaufen, und so hat die Haare geschwungen. Aber es war auch egal, was er untenrum anhatte, weil es nur um die Haare ging. Er ist um Jogginghose an wahrscheinlich. Ja, Moment, aber was präsentiert man denn auf einer Haarmodel-Modenschau? Ja, da sind halt verschiedene Friseure, die machen die Haare zuerst und dann machen die Werbung für verschiedene Produkte wahrscheinlich. Oder Tönungen wahrscheinlich auch. Moment, da gibt es dann echte Modeschaus nur für Haare oder wie? Ja, nur für Haare. Es gibt auch Modeschaus nur für Fingernägel. Ich will mal ein Bild von dem sehen, das interessiert mich jetzt, wie der aussieht. Wie heisst der denn? Ja, wahrscheinlich so George wie du. Ja, wow. Aber das Problem ist jetzt, dass er halt ganz wenig Haare hat. Oh Gott. Auf jeden Fall, der studiert jetzt Psychologie, wie mein Vater, und ist jetzt ganz vernünftig. Okay, aber war das gerade so ein Anfang von einer sehr traurigen Geschichte, als er war Haarmodel, hat fallen an glücklich zu werden in seinem Leben und dann hat er gemerkt, dass er Haar verliert und so Geheimratsecken bekommen und dann konnte er diesen Weg nicht weitergehen. Und er hat gesagt, was mache ich jetzt, studiere Psychologie. Psychologie oder Philosophie, ja. Ja, so wie so ein Fingermodel, das langsam die Finger verliert oder so, ist ja tatsächlich ein Problem. Zum Beispiel mein Gitarrenlehrer, der hat einen Finger verloren in einem Unfall und er ist seine ganze Karriere darauf aufgebaut, dass er Gitarrenlehrer ist und selber Gitarren hat, hat den Finger verloren, aber er hat verloren von der rechten Hand den kleinen Finger. Das ist der einzige Finger, den man nicht zum Gitarrenspielen braucht. Und da hat er die Hälfte verloren. Von der rechten Hand der kleine Finger. Hat er die Hände versichern lassen vorher? Ich glaube nicht, aber ich weiss nicht, aber ich finde es ein Riesenzufall. Alle ausser denen! Ja, aber ich finde es ein Riesenzufall, dass gerade ein Gitarrenlehrer einen Finger verliert, was mega scheiße, aber dann genau den, den man nicht braucht. Alle anderen wären Stress gewesen, nur der einzige nicht. Das war schon nicht schlecht. Nein, ach ja, komm scheiße, nicht so wild eigentlich. Ich glaube, er hat sich enorm gefreut in der Situation, obwohl es eine sehr furchtbare Situation ist. Na gut, aber er hat sich wahrscheinlich gedacht, na gut, ich werde wahrscheinlich nie wieder einen anderen Finger verlieren, weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr gering, das heisst, ich bin eigentlich safe. Aber das ist aber die falsche Denkweise. Ich glaube, wenn du einmal für den Ritz getroffen wirst, dann denkst du ... Wenn man einmal auf Rot gesetzt hat und dann kommt Schwarz, sollte man auch trotzdem, ist die Chance immer noch 50-50. Also die Chance, dass du noch mal einen Finger verlierst, ist trotzdem noch genauso. Ne, ist 25 Prozent, dass zweimal Schwarz kommt. Ja. Also ihr setzt immer in Casinos, wenn rot kommt, danach schwarz, und wenn schwarz kommt, danach rot, dann habt ihr eine höhere Gewinnchance. Cash Cash Cash! Kennt ihr das Stück Rosenkranz und Güldenstein? Hm, okay, da fängt das Stück an, wo sie hunderttausendmal Coin hoch machen. Kommt der Zahl. Immer auf Zahl. Ist ein tolles Stück. Kann auch passieren. Es war aber jetzt nur bei der einen Vorstellung, oder wie? Also das war so, ey Leute, wir müssen die ganz kurz abbrechen, das ist mega krass, was hier gerade passiert.
Holt irgendwie so einen Lotto-Typ mal her oder so, krass gerade.
Aber das wäre auch geil, wenn die Prämisse eines Stückes darauf aufgebaut ist, dass es immer funktioniert, aber man halt irgendwann merkt, ja, ich habe jetzt halt direkt Zahl geworfen, sorry, und dann die Vor schau, schau, geh zu, Leute, enttäuscht nach Hause, das klappt nur einmal, hat es geklappt, jemand.
Ja, genauso wie dieser eine Aktionskünstler, der sich auf der Bühne seinen Penis abgeschnitten hat, wo ich mir auch denke, so, gerade in dem Moment irgendwie hupt draußen Auto oder so und alle gucken gerade weg und so, nein, Leute, fuck, ey, was war das denn?
Das war nur einmal möglich.
Und dann einfach, scheiße, ja, es gibt halt keine zweite Vorstellung. Oder es gibt die Vorstellung, die... Ich schnappe den Arm ab, so Leute, mir ist alles scheißegal. Und jetzt, wie sehen wir, wie der Penis wieder angenäht wird? Ja. Das könnte auch... Das stimmt. Man hofft immer, dass man in der Vorstellung sitzt, bevor er sich wieder abschneidet. Man betet so in eins, kein zu Hause. Betet nicht die Armee, genau wie der Titanic Teil zwei erzählt, wie das Schiff wieder aufgeht.
Ja, genau.
What the fuck, damit hat niemand gerechnet.
Don't spoil it, no spoilers. Du hast gerade gesagt, dass du in L.A. gewohnt hast und dann irgendwann gesagt hast, ich habe keinen Bock mehr, in L.A. zu wohnen und zurückgezogen bist.
Wir waren jetzt nur in New York, waren aber so dermassen hinweg von dieser Stadt, dass wir uns nicht vorstellen können, dass jemand in eine amerikanische Stadt zieht und irgendwann da keinen Bock mehr drauf hat.
Was ist passiert?
Mein Freund hat die Nanny gebumst. Ah, alles klar, okay. True story, funny, aber das war nicht der Grund. Ich hasse diese Stadt der Sünde! Stadt der Engel, wohl eher Stadt der Teufel! So, wenn man so findet die Stadt die Stadt von Teufeln fällt einem kein cooler Spruch ein. Man schliesst vom Straßenausgangsschild, Stadt der Engel, wohl eher nicht. Und hoffentlich hat es niemand so Glück, hat mich niemand gesehen. Eins, zwei, drei. Ja, das ist auch so etwas so blöd, wenn man stirbt und gerade angeschossen wird, so als Soldat im Zweiten Weltkrieg und gerade so sterbend in den Armen seiner Kollegen liegt und dann noch irgendwie den letzten Satz sagt, aber so, irgendein fällt einem irgendwie nichts ein und man sagt, du bist so ein schlechter Gag oder sowas. Aber wie war, wie ist der Rapper Tupac, der ist erscheint erschossen worden, erschossen worden und dann kam die Polizei und hat gesagt, who was it, who was it und der hat das gemacht, hat zwei Finger hochgezogen. Tupac hat im Sterben liegen, die könnten auch Krämpfe gelesen sein, man weiß es nicht. That's the way to go. Ich glaube, der schlechteste letzte Satz ist irgendwie so, aua, aua, mein Gott, tut das weh, oder so, wenn du gerade angeschossen wurdest. Oder, ja ... Au, ouchie, nicht in diesem Shirt. Ich glaube, auch wenn man so Panik hat oder sowas, dann denkt man irgendwie ganz komische random Sachen so, also zum Beispiel ein Kumpel von mir, der ist ... Wir haben so gedreht auf ein Boot und wir mussten von einem Boot zum anderen, also nicht Boot, aber so ein Schifflein, ein oder noch alles hält, und der ist halt irgendwie ins Wasser gefallen, ja, und der hatte beide seine Handys, also er hatte zwei Handys, hat beide Handys in den Taschen, kurz vorher reingefallen. Alle sieben Handys hat er in einer Hosentasche gerade. Seinen Laptop auch in der Hand. Die Ohne seiner Mutter hat er im Rucksack und alles. Ich darf jetzt nicht ins Wasser fallen. Nein, ich falle jetzt ins Wasser. Warum drehe ich gerade auf einem Schifflein, was soll das? Auf jeden Fall hat er gesagt, so, komplett runter ins Wasser, ja, Kopf runter. Und er hat gesagt, sein erster Gedanke war, kann man mit Turnschuhen schwimmen? Ah, ja. Und ich glaube auch, ich habe auch so einen Podcast gehört und es ging darum, dass die Mutter erfahren hat, die Tochter war irgendwie so ein bisschen psychisch unnabil und die Mutter so, wo ist sie, wo ist sie, ich habe so Angst, ich glaube, sie bringt sich um und ich habe um vier einen Friseurtermin. Sollen sie es entweder jetzt machen oder gar nicht, aber ... Weil ich weiss jetzt nicht, wo ich das jetzt machen soll. Aber so ging es mir auch. Als wir in New York waren, haben wir einen Morgen ... Wir haben die ganze Zeit nur Scheiss gefressen, wir haben wirklich nur Kalorien zu uns genommen, einfach pure Kalorien, teilweise auch nur pures Fett, Butter gegessen. Und dann habe ich einen Morgen nach einem richtig krassen Frühstück gedacht, ich sterbe, und ich werde einen Herzinfarkt haben, weil ich habe auch meinen linken Arm nicht mehr gespürt, das komplett durch und ich war im central park und habe davor einen star wars soundtrack gehört da dachte ich mir okay jetzt in dieser panik habe ich gedacht also in der ich dachte dass ich einen herzinfarkt bekomme ich könnte jetzt sterben und ich war dabei es ist krass wie geil musik ist ja man dachte auch also ich dachte auch das ist der letzte song zu dem ich sterbe ja und ich war auch dabei und du lagst in meinen armen Komisch, dass du das jetzt nicht erwähnt hast. Du hast die Haare gestrichelt. Stefan hat wirklich schöne Haare, das lohnt sich dann auch mal schön sich zu bedienen. Als Haarmodel habe ich mal angestrebt, aber dann hat mir so ein Junge namens George, hat mir die weggenommen. Den letzten Platz. Damn you George! Damn you and your beautiful hair! Damn! Ach ja. Ach Mensch. Aber was vermisst du am meisten? Also ich habe am meisten die Schwarzen vermisst in Deutschland. Als ich zurückgekommen bin, ist mir das aufgefallen. Die lebenden Schwarzen. Die sind nur Weisse, überall in Deutschland. Das ist krass. Es hängen nur Weisse ab. Ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, ich bin ja nach New York 2011 und ich wollte eigentlich nur zu Besuch, so zwei Monate wollte ich mal hin. Und ich bin in so Airtrain reingegangen, ihr kennt ja das erste, und dann in den U-Bahn.
Und ich sass da mit so einem grossen Koffer und auf einmal kommen halt sieben, acht Leute, die gerade die Security gemacht haben, die waren fertig. Und die waren super krass laut, super gross, schwarz, die haben sich gegenseitig angeschrien, die hatten so Handys auf laut gemacht, haben Musik gehört, gelacht und ich sass da und ich so, ey, ich will hier wohnen.
Das war so ein geiles Gefühl, so einfach lebendig, laut und so ein schönes Gefühl.
Vor allem, wir waren in Harlem, haben wir gewohnt. In Harlem ist einfach, da siehst du dann einfach ganz oft keinen Weissen mehr.
In Harlem bin ich mal zu einer Gospel gegangen.
Zu so einem Gottesdienst, da wollten wir hin, aber haben wir nicht gemacht. Oh, happy day, oh, happy day, oh, happy day, when Jesus was downstairs. Aber was wir auch gehört haben über dich, dass du Improv gemacht hast. Ja. Und wir als der Podcast, der versucht seit Jahren, in Deutschland Improv groß zu machen, weil wir andauernd unsere kleinen Hörspielchen einbauen. Die niemand hören will und die Leute sogar jetzt uns Geld geben, damit wir aufhören, Hörspiel zu machen. Ja, wo wir einfach versuchen, zwischendurch so ein bisschen nonchalant, ein bisschen hinterher zu improvisieren, das versuchen wir langsam so ein bisschen zu etablieren. Aber total krass, was hast du denn da gelernt? Also ich dachte, dass du uns vielleicht helfen kannst, dass unsere Hörspiele endlich mal massentauglich werden. Also du bist reingekommen zu UCB, der grossen Improv-Gemeinschaft da, und was war der erste Tipp, den die gesagt haben? Be funny, genau. Ja, die Klasse ist yes and. Also nicht zumachen, sondern einfach weitermachen. Okay, open-minded sein. Also wenn jemand ein Setting anbietet, dann nicht direkt verweigern, sondern einfach sagen, okay, ich nehme es an und lege noch was oben drauf. Was zum Beispiel bei uns beim Schultheater oft so war, wenn wir improvisiert haben, da haben die Leute das dann immer irgendwie sofort ins Lächerliche gezogen. Zum Beispiel jemand hat gespielt, wie er sich gerade einen Galgen um den Hals legt und sich erhängen will und dann irgendwie kam sofort einer rein und hat gesagt, okay, das ist schon das dritte Mal die Woche, was soll das? Also so das Setting, das der eine angeboten hat, mit mega Ernst, hat die überhaupt nicht interessiert, sondern er hat mal direkt einen Gag gemacht und gleich weg oder direkt so getan, als würden sie das nur im Fernsehen sehen oder so.
Genau, ja, ja.
Oder halt sofort irgendwie eine zweite Idee, auch seine Idee draufgepackt, anstatt dessen Idee erstmal anzunehmen.
Das Problem haben wir auch irgendwie bei uns, dass wir immer irgendwie eher zu narzisstisch sind und immer selber den besseren Gag machen wollen und gar nicht irgendwie nachdenken, was könnte der andere meinen, wie kann ich jetzt eher bei ihm weitermachen. Wir sind aber auch zu hektisch, wir sind zu hektisch, wir wollen dann immer direkt in eine andere Richtung einschlagen, die nächste Metaebene nehmen, alle Gags mitnehmen, die gerade im Raum stehen und so. Das ist, glaube ich, auch ein Problem, weil Yes And sagt ja auch, man nimmt erstmal die Situation an und damit es nicht ins Stocken gerät, versucht man nicht erst mal direkt einen Gag zu machen, sondern einfach irgendwas dazu zu sagen.
Genau, also es ist ja ja genau und auch die Beziehung, dass man sagt, okay, wenn er zum Beispiel die Geigen hat, dass man sagt, George, was machst du oder Robert, was machst du da, dass man halt die Beziehung hat, zuhört, ist auch das Grösste, aber es ist krass, wie lange das dauert, um das zu lernen, weil es gibt ja vier, man muss sozusagen vier Courses machen. Also es geht so UCB one, two, three und jeweils geht einer Kurs acht Wochen. Um das mal ganz kurz festzulegen, UCB Upright Citizen Brigade ist so dieses grosse Comedy-Kollektiv-Club, es gibt zwei Locations in New York, da waren wir beide. Die gefühlt Improv irgendwie erfunden haben. Genau, da gibt es halt viele Improv-Shows, da waren auch viele grosse Stars, die da irgendwie mal rausgekommen sind.
Ja, ich denke, Amy Poehler in Chicago. Genau, also viele Leute irgendwie auch Improv for Humans, Matt Besser ist auch einer der grossen, der hat auch seinen eigenen Improv-Podcast und so. Und das ist halt so ein bisschen auch so die Talentschmiede irgendwie und die Leute, die Bock haben, da kommen zu machen. Genau, ja. Wir haben da zwei Shows gesehen, die waren mega gut, die waren total geflasht. Ass Cats, Ass Cats ist halt die Improv-Show, die war unberagend. Unglaublich.
Und dann haben wir noch Gentrify gesehen, gibt es auch einen Podcast, wo dann halt so
auch Sketchgruppen auftauchen, aber vornehmlich Stand-Up und halt Leute, die so drei Hosts, die so Podcast-mäßig einfach die ganze Zeit improvisieren mit dem Publikum, auch mega grossartig einfach. Und da gibt es dann so ein Level-System oder wie funktioniert das, wenn man da jetzt selber teilnehmen will, wie funktioniert das? Genau, also man muss bezahlen und dann musst du halt unten anfangen, Level eins, und das geht so ungefähr acht Wochen, einmal die Woche, und dann kannst du ins zweite, dritte und vierte. Und gibt es dann auch sowas wie Prüfungen, dass du dann weiterkommen musst, oder bist du automatisch Level zwei, wenn du... Ja, genau. Aber wie viel hast du gemacht? Kann auch jeder macht, drei. Du hast drei gemacht, okay, also kurz vorher hast du gesagt. Ja, also kein Geld mehr. Also kein musstest davor irgendwie so eine Eignung zeigen oder kannst du einfach bezahlen? Nee, du kannst einfach alle machen. Geil, ey. Und es gibt… Haben wir das nicht gemacht. Das heisst, weil wir nur eine Woche da waren, das grösste Problem daran. Scheiße, aber es gibt es auch in L.A., UCB L.A. Ja, es gibt auch L.A., Chicago, New York. Nächstes Jahr acht Wochen, würde ich, schön in die Staaten, einfach mal Level eins erstmal. Geil. Das ist geil, das ist cool. Und die Prüfung ist halt keine Prüfung, sondern am Ende macht man halt eine Show vor Publikum. In diesem, wo ihr wart, wo ihr wahrscheinlich eine der Shows gesehen habt, ja. Also wirklich angsteinflössig gut. Das Prinzip ist ja, was ja auch viele nicht wissen, ist nicht einfach, dass Leute die ganze Zeit Sachen reinrufen aus dem Publikum und Leute das dann adaptieren. Das passiert ja nur einmal, dass jemand was reinruft, dann wird er von so einem Monologisten, also halt irgendwer, der berühmt da ist oder so, wird dann das Wort aufgegriffen und er erzählt dann irgendeine Story aus seinem Leben, die ihm gerade dazu einfällt und auf Basis dessen fangen die dann an zu improvisieren, was ja ja auch schon ein geiles System ist, vor allem weil das so, ich habe mir jetzt auch dieses Buch von denen gekauft, dieses Manual, was total geil ist, weil die das ja einfach, einfach dieses dicke, das ist so eine dicke Comedy-Bibel einfach, also ihr werdet sehen, in den nächsten Wochen wird sie einfach abgefeuert, das Gag-Vorwerk. Aber das ist total geil zu sehen, wie viele Gedanken da reingeflossen sind, nicht nur in, nicht nur da rein, wie man lustig ist, sondern auch einfach ins Handwerk erstmal, auf das man aufbauen muss. Dann kannst du anfangen, lustig zu sein und so, aber das ist erstmal ja auch Arbeit. Also, strengt euch da an mal, Leute. Arbeitend! Wir sind leger gekleidet auch gerade, so ein bisschen, ja, ja geil, cool, aber du hast dann trotzdem nicht weitergemacht, trotzdem kein Rock of L.A.? Ja, also ich hab, ja, es ist so ein bisschen schwierig, aber ich war, ich hatte irgendwie Heimweh. Vielleicht ist es wahrscheinlich das beste Gefühl, was ich so geben kann. Und es war auch das, ich bin hierhin und wusste auch nicht so ganz genau, ich wusste, ich wollte nicht mehr in L.A. bleiben irgendwie und kam dann hierhin und dann hat eigentlich alles so gut, so schnell funktioniert hier für mich, dass ich gedacht habe … Du, die nehmen hier jeden. Ja, wirklich, es gibt niemanden einfach in Deutschland. Wirklich. Es freuen sich einfach an Leute, wenn ein Mädchen was Comedy macht, yay! Ja, ja, das wusste ich nicht, das ist gut zu wissen. Aber es war, ja, also … Ja, es ist schwer zu erklären, aber es war irgendwann mal war es mir zu ... also diese ... Es gibt alle guten Seiten von Amerika, aber es gibt halt auch diese ein bisschen oberflächlich und alle ... Ich hatte so viele Freunde, aber keine richtigen so und das ... Nach einer Weile, wenn man halt auch ... also ich habe ja das Deutsche auch im Blut und man weiss, wie es sich echt anfühlt ... Das Hakenkreuz, das er auf der gestehen tätowiert. Ja, genau. Da war es halt so irgendwie, ja. Ja, aber hier in Deutschland machst du jetzt auch Stand-Up, ne, in Berlin. Genau, ja. Warst du auch schon mal in Köln, hast du auch schon mal in Köln Stand-Up gemacht? Nee, ich war in Leipzig, Hamburg. Schade, ich dachte, dass du, weil du mal angesprochen hast, dass du hier in Deutschland, in Köln auch Stand-Up mal machen könntest, theoretisch. Ja, also ich könnte, ich könnte jetzt am Montag oder sowas machen, aber mal gucken. Weil wir waren auch mal hier in Köln und haben Stand-up gemacht, im Boeing. Hast du das im Boeing schon wieder? Ja geil, ja cool, Wolf heisst der, weisst du? Ja, Manuel Wolf. Der hat sogar geliked, dass ich noch nicht in Köln komme. Boing, ich finde das ... Aber das war wirklich ... Und dann geht es KGB? Ja, das KGB, genau, das gibt's hier auch. Ist nicht dieser sowjetische Geheimdienst oder was? Ja. Aber die sind mega lustig, die Geheimdienst und Stand-up. Und Sketch-Truppe, wuh! Wir waren jetzt neulich wieder im Boeing und es ist doch ein bisschen erstaunlich, was hier dann doch auf die Bühne gelassen wird, was natürlich auch gut ist. Oh, Kulturkritik-Tiese, aber es war schon ein bisschen ernüchternd. Es war ein bisschen unangenehm, wir sassen ja zu zweit auf so einer Fensterbank irgendwie, da war so ein riesiges Fenster hinter uns, wo dann immer im Laufe der Show immer Passanten an uns vorbeigelaufen sind, die sich dann so zwischen uns und durch die Fensterscheibe der Show zugeschaut haben und direkt zwischen uns standen, aber es war halt eine Fensterscheibe zwischen uns, es war so ein ganz komisches Gefühl, es war irgendwie wie so ein Vater, den wir hier hatten. Aber du guckst Comedy die ganze Zeit und dann plötzlich siehst du hinter dir so einen Schatten, dreht sich nicht oben und dann steht da einfach so ein sehr gruseliger Mensch, der einfach die ganze Zeit und will halt die Show gucken, kann es aber auch nicht wirklich hören, also er dachte irgendwie, das war so eine visuelle Show, aber es war auch Comedy, es funktioniert auch viel über die Ohren. Und er konnte es ja nicht hören, was da gesagt wird. Er steht einfach da und alle lachen sich den Arsch ab und er steht da einfach draußen und guckt einfach die Show. Er hätte den hier machen sollen. Ja. Riecht so in die Fresse haben. Visuell kann man nicht. Nee, nee, wir machen demnächst die Webcam ein. Wir haben ein paar Gifs raus dazu, würde ich sagen, einfach so mit Timecalls, mit den Leuten das genau, dass wir irgendwie sehen können. Kochst du gerne? Nee. Schwimmen? Ich kann immer nicht kochen. Hast du fetzige Hobbys, was cool ist, was man, irgendwie so Cosplay oder so, oder wie so ein Roboter sich bewegen, macht dir das Spass, hast du viel mit Robotern oder machst du gar nichts mit? Ich hab das Gefühl, du willst, dass ich irgendwas mit Robotern muss. Nee, aber ich hab ein bisschen Alufolie da, wenn du mal, also wenn du, wer jetzt nur. Nee, ich hab immer in New York und in LA und ich will mir auch hier einkaufen so einen Scooter. Ich liebe Scooter fahren, nicht Scooter, sondern so eine Vespa, das ist so mein Hobby. Wir haben jetzt Scooter, drei Elektro-Scooter, hier die Firma, in der du gerade sich befindest. Was? Wir haben drei Elektro-Scooter. Ja genau, wir haben nämlich so zwei Hubs, einmal so das Studio und einmal so die Büro, und um da hin und her zu fahren, haben wir jetzt drei Elektroscooter. Das ist unglaublich. Das ist so geil. Das ist richtig geil. Wir arbeiten alle auch gar nicht mehr, wir fahren nur auf Scootern hin und her. Kann ich drüben die Flaschen holen? Okay, alles klar, ich bin so ein paar Mal drüber. Wenn wir nicht gerade mit einer Limone spielen, dann spielen wir mit Scooter. Ja. Aber das macht voll Spaß. Ich habe immer so Musik, ich bin sehr, sehr gefährlich gefahren. Ich hatte immer so Chips gegessen, Musik gehört, mit einer Hand gefahren. Geil, ich habe da bei Geige gespielt. Und das Geile war halt, die letzten paar Monate waren echt schon cool in Venice, ja, und man fährt das Sommer im Bikini an so und ich weiss immer so, mit dieser Musik, was weiss ich, Beyonce, Und ich bin like, ah, I'm the top top of the world, ja und dann hält man so bei rot und man guckt so, man groovt und guckt so rüber und da ist so eine Scheibe und man sieht sich und das ist so, alter Schwede und so, mein Bauch guckt raus, meine Haare sind so und die Chips und so, das ist so wie ein Reality-Clash. Oh Gott, ja. Aber auch wenn man diese Collagen sieht, wo Leute dann so Roller fahren, Kids in America rumfahren, Chipstüte in der Hand, es ist selten rot, die Ampeln sind dann selten, in diesem Bild. Es ist dann so eine Collage, wo man sich dann so zunickt, yeah, und dann so dem anderen grüßt und dann so Gas gibt, genau, aber es ist eigentlich nie rot und es geht auch nie Sachen schief. Ich finde es geil, wenn man so eine Collage einfach komplett alles in Bach untergehen würde. Realität, so eher so. Wo alle an der Ampel warten müssen, so Jogger oder so gehen und warten. Ich habe nämlich in Harlem, da muss ich einmal einkaufen gehen, da habe ich Fatboy Slim gehört, Praise You. Geiler Song einfach, um einfach so durch Harlem zu laufen. Und es kam halt genau als der Break am Anfang kam, bin ich halt die Treppe runter von unserem geilen Apartment in Harlem und bin dann so los und dachte mir, das ist wie so eine Filmcollage gerade, in der ich mich befinde. Läht aber mein Schnürsenkel auf, ich muss ihn einmal in der Tasche abstellen und dann ... So und schau, da könntest du dich kurz durchlassen und so. Und dann bin ich im Weg, dann bin ich zur Seite gegangen und dann musste ich mein Schnürsenkel zumachen und dann war der alles, der geile Moment war dann einfach weg, aber das ist Realität. Ja, die Lidl-Tüte. Ich war dieses Jahr in San Francisco für Neujahr bei der Band Flaming Lips. Kennt ihr die? Flaming Lips. Flaming Lips. Auf jeden Fall morgens, ganz früh morgens, wir waren alle im Hotelraum, wir waren alle drauf und so. Und ich bin um sieben Uhr morgens losgegangen und hab halt Musik gehört und zwar Eminem, ich bin voll der krasse Eminem-Fan. Wir sind Emmett-Emms-Fans. Ja, du... Das ist nämlich die...
Nee, ich sag doch überhaupt nichts.
Wenn Blick sagt Nein, aber du solltest sagen Ja.
Ja, okay. Ich hab überhaupt nichts gesagt.
Auf jeden Fall bin ich so durch San Francisco gelaufen und ich wusste das nicht, aber ich war in so einer richtig krassen Ghetto-Area, ja, wo es halt, wo es sogar, es gibt so Needle Dispensaries, das heisst, weil die alle so heroinabhängig sind, gibt es so richtige spezielle Mülleimer für diese Dinge jetzt. What, warum muss man die gesondert entsorgen? Ich dachte, man holt sich saubere Nadeln. Man holt sich saubere und dann gibt es auch das, wo man sie reinwirft. Ah, okay. Wenn die recycelt oder nicht. Damit keine andere die übernimmt. Damit die, die dann die Mülleimer durchwühlen, nicht in eine Spritze packen wahrscheinlich.
Ja, genau.
Das kann natürlich auch sein, ne?
Ja. Und ich laufe so und da stehen so vier so Ghetto-Schwarze und ich fühlte mich so cool, dass ich so vorbeigelaufen bin und denen so ein Nard gegeben habe. So Nard. Und die N-Bombe gedroppt hat. Und ich glaube mit der Sekunde, weil ich war so, wie gesagt, ich hatte so, es war ein bisschen kalt, aber ich hatte so einen Jack an, aber so Strumpfhosen, also es war wie Folgeparty mit so Glitzer und so. Und ich glaube, in der Sekunde habe ich denen Angst gemacht. Aber auf jeden Fall bin ich weitergelaufen und ich so, okay, ey, geil, ich will über Rot laufen. Ich will, dass die sehen, dass ich so voll Ghetto bin und über Rot laufe, so in meinem Kopf. Ich will, dass sie meine Waffe sehen. Deswegen zeige ich auf sie mit meiner Waffe. Ich glaube, die dachten einfach, du bist so eine Undercover-Polizistin, die einfach so Hey, my boys, hey, what's up, what's going on? Und die einfach so, okay, alles klar. You got weed? You got weed? I like to buy some of that grass. Aber hast du im Englischen einen deutschen Akzent? Pitti, pitti, p. Also sagen Leute, du bist doch Deutsche. Nee, die hören nicht deutsch raus, aber ein bisschen aggressiv. Aber bist doch ein Deutscher, was ist du denn hier? Aber so leicht und über, ganz, ganz leicht irgendwas hört man so ein bisschen raus. Aber nicht immer. Okay. Not always. Aber hast du auch verschiedene englische Sprachen, also kannst du zwischen jetzt einem New-Yorker und einem L. Dialekt irgendwie switchen oder hast du so einen Mischmasch irgendwie? Ich habe so einen ganz klaren, ich habe wenn irgendwas New Jersey, also so ein bisschen mehr andere Sachen, amerikanische und sein eigenes Englisch ist so ein Mischmasch oder so, wie sich das anhören muss für Amerikaner irgendwie. Das ist wie wenn ein Amerikaner immer nur deutsche Serien schaut und dann so ein bisschen bayerisch, ein bisschen sächsisch verschiedener und so ein Mischdialekt hat, wie sich das für uns anhören. Das haben wir nicht, weil bei uns das deutsche Fernsehen noch alles hochdeutsch ist und so, aber wie sich das für einen Amerikaner anhören muss, für jemanden, der immer nur so einzelne Bruchteile hört und sich da irgendwie selber was zusammenbastelt, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Wir beide sind ja auch relativ, wir haben ja offensiv auch Englisch gesprochen, und ich glaube, wir sprechen auch nicht so schlecht Englisch, aber das ist halt, glaube ich, auch, also wenn man die Sprache, ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, wie jemand, der relativ gut Deutsch spricht, einfach so diese ganzen Einflüsse verbindet, das ist halt ein Problem. Also dann, manche Sachen sagt man britisch, aber im selben Satz sagt man ein Wort britisch und ein anderes dann irgendwie amerikanisch oder so. Das ist dann ganz komisch irgendwie. Mich haben die gefragt, ob ich aus Montreal komme. Zum ersten Mal in Amerika war auch eine sehr spezifische Frage. Also das ist direkt so eine Stadt zu fragen, kommst du aus Stuttgart? Ja, wieder? Hm? Nein? Das fand ich eine sehr seltsame Frage. Aber die Holländer hören sich auch so ein bisschen amerikanisch an. So ihr, oder? Die Holländer? Holland ist ja auch das Amerika von Europa so ein bisschen. Wir unterbrechen die Sendung für eine technische Podcast-Störung, wir sind gleich wieder da. Ja, falls ihr hier schneiden wollt. Ähm, ja. Ähm. Was noch? Was noch, was haben wir noch? Wir haben ein bisschen was vorbereitet. Also, was hast du, ach wir sind einfach hier. Ich sag, ja. Fühl dich einfach locker. Erzähl mal, hau mal ein bisschen was raus, erzähl mal ein bisschen was. Okay, okay, was ist das zu wissen? Wann warst du das letzte Mal so richtig nass? Weil es gerade regnet.
So richtig nass.
So geduscht hast du. Sorry, Entschuldigung. Okay, das ist ein geiles Segway rüber, aber okay, ich erzähl mal so meine Most-LA-Geschichte ever. Und zwar war ich in Malibu auf Liam Hemsworths Geburtstag.
What the hell?
Aber, ja, und deswegen war aber eigentlich wollten wir nicht ihn besuchen, sondern Miley Cyrus.
Wir waren auf Miley Cyrus Freunds Geburtstag.
Und eigentlich war es nur so, dass ich und jemand was bringen sollten. Ja, okay. Wir haben überhaupt diese alle so eigentlich, man denkt ja, dass die voll viele Drogen macht und nimmt und sowas, aber eigentlich gar nicht so. Moment, aber wie seid ihr überhaupt da reingekommen in diese Kreise? Okay, so mein Kumpel, der ist Filmemacher, also der ist Cinematographer und der hat ihre letzten zwei Videos gemacht, aber dieser Kumpel ist halt so, der ist so ein, wie kann ich den erklären, ich habe den immer Ketchup genannt, weil er immer nur so, der war so ein bisschen übergewichtigt, hat immer so rote T-Shirts an und war so voll so Waldorfschüler und so, also richtig so und der hatte nicht eine grosse Ausbildung, aber war halt irgendwie, der ist so mit einer anderen Band getourt und mit denen hat Miley Cyrus hat mit denen zusammengearbeitet und deswegen hat er einfach nur so diese Videos gedreht, wo sie halt ganz nah irgendwie so Eis laggt oder sowas. Auf jeden Fall haben wir gedacht, der so, ja kommst du mit? Und ich so, ja klar, ein Auto wurde uns abgeholt, wir sind hingefahren und wir dachten, das ist eine Party, aber im Endeffekt waren es nur Liam Hemsworth, Miley Cyrus und noch so ein anderer Typ, der so ... What, nee, zu viert war der dann fünf da? Ja, fünf da, so sechs Stunden lang. Und das Geile ist so, ich habe ihr so voll viel von meiner Mutter erzählt, weil ich so richtig casual sein wollte und so, ey, ist überhaupt kein Ding, ich chill hier mit Miley Cyrus so. Das ist gerade der erste Moment, wo ich mit jemandem spreche, der sechs Stunden lang mit einem krassen Weltstar verbracht hat. Eigentlich schon, ne? Wirklich? Ja. Und dann, aber das Geile war halt, ein Moment, also die ist super nett, so Pyjamas an, aber die geile, das Geile war, sie ist … Niemand ist böse in Pyjamas, niemand ist ein Arschloch in Pyjamas.
Die hat ein Ding gemacht, das war ein bisschen merkwürdig, so die wohnen in einer Riesenvilla und die sind gerade zusammengezogen, ja.
Und wir sitzen so in der Küche und labern, ich erzähle ihr von meiner Mutter, und also während sie so redet, steht sie auf und zieht sich die Schlafanzughose runter, springt auf die Spüle, weisst du, so wo man die Hände wäscht, also Spüle von der Küche und pinkelt. What? Vor allem auch in der Reihenfolge, dass sie sich erst die Hose runterzieht und dann auf dem Waschbein. Ganz kurz, ich finde die Reihenfolge das Normalste an der Geschichte. Ja, das ist geil erst pinkeln. Warte mal, sie hatte Pyjamas, das ist aber merkwürdig. Hm, ich würde erst aus Waschbecken springen und dann meine Hose runterziehen. Weil du kannst ja, wenn du die Hose runtergezogen hast, schon nicht mehr gut springen. Aber sie hat ja nicht… Ich habe mir das so wie eine Katze vor. Aber sie hat sie ja nicht komplett runtergezogen, sondern… Ach so. Aber ich glaube, ich habe so einfach das Arsch, Arsch raus und dann hochgehupft, ausgerutscht, auf dem Arsch gefallen. Wir haben alle so getan, als ob es nicht passiert wäre.
Nee, das hat sie nicht gemacht.
Ja krass, aber das ist ganz schön crazy gerade. Und dann hat sie so gepickt, aber es war irgendwie überhaupt gar nicht merkwürdig, irgendwie. Ja. Ne, also es war irgendwie so, ja okay, aber dann war es so, dass sie irgendwie, die hat mir so, like Crips, weißt du, so Crips, die hat mir die ganze Wohnung gezeigt, also die ganze Villa gezeigt, ja, und sie hat mir die aber zweimal gezeigt, da habe ich so gemerkt, die ist so ein bisschen off, ja, weil wir gingen dann durch die Räume raus. Oder die Geschichten über die Räume zweimal, ihr habt jetzt erzählt. Nee, aber sie hat irgendwie so ganz merkwürdig, also das ist so, sie, wir kamen in diesen Raum und der war voll bunt und sowas, aber sie hat die ganze Zeit immer nur gesagt, okay, das ist mein Kissen, das ist Liams Kissen, das ist Liams Kissen und das ist mein Kissen. Sie hat mir nur erzählt, wen, welches Kissen gehört. Vielleicht arbeitet sie gerade bei uns neuen Song oder so, gleich ist der der Refrain. Und dann haben wir beim zweiten Durchgang, habe ich dann gesagt so, nee, nee, das ist mein Kissen. Sie hat den Witz nicht verstanden, ich fand ihn wirklich krass. Holy shit, alles echt krass. Aber ist das normaler, dass man da so mit Promis abhängt oder so? Aber ich meine, die haben doch auch nicht so mehr Promis als wir, oder warum sind die denn nahbar? Das verstehe ich nicht. Weil die alle, die meisten wohnen ja alle da. Also ist es ruhig so, dass jeder den... Aber Bill Burr, das ist mein … den fand ich am geilsten. Du hast Bill Burr getroffen? Ich habe nach Bill Burr aufgetreten. What in LA? Ja, das ist aber auch keine grosse Sache, also das ist überhaupt nicht jetzt so, oh geil, sondern der kam in … Wir haben so eine Show gemacht, so Bringer-Show, das heisst das in Deutschland, in Amerika. Das heisst, du musst so und so viele Leute mitbringen, die fünfzehn Dollar bezahlen, um in einen Club reinzugehen und zwei Getränke kaufen müssen, um mediocre Comedy Stand-up zu sehen. Okay, mediocre oder Bill Burr. Nee, und dann Bill Burr kommt manchmal halt, der hat so seine Show und die sind ja drei Räume ins Comedy Store und dann kommt er einfach rein und sagt so, ich mach auch mal ein bisschen was, ja. Und ja, das waren die echt die schlimmsten sieben
Minuten meines Lebens danach, weil ich hab ihm noch die Hand geben können so und danach ich so,
ja, Bill Burr war gerade auf der Bühne und jetzt komme ich.
Holy shit, er war dein Support quasi, er war dein Support Act.
Er war mein Opener.
Er war der Opener, ja.
Nee, er kam halt nur rein und hat gesagt, aber der war echt cool. Ja, also sorry, aber ich habe jetzt keine Geschichte, die jetzt nur anderswo. Ja, ich war letztens beim Netto und dann habe ich eine Avocado gesehen, die ein bisschen matschiger war als die anderen. Wirklich? Nein. Das ist so bei uns, das geht so bei uns ab. Aber wie kommt man jetzt aus der Geschichte, hast du noch andere Leute getroffen? Also wenn Bill Burr,isirous, Liam Hemsworth ... Ich will jetzt eine ganze Liste von dir einfach an. Ich hab bei Law & Order mitgespielt, da hab ich diese ... Wie heissen die, diesen Rapper? Ice-Tea? Ice-Tea kennengelernt. Geil. Und ich glaube, ich hatte Ron-DMC Pullover an, als ich den gesehen hab. Ach geil. Ja, ist es jetzt ... Sind die ... Ich weiss es nicht, aber ich hab nur gerade das gesehen, weil ich den Pulli immer noch hier hatte. Das wäre auch so ein Ding, weil ich würde auch nie so was so Rap-mässige Sachen tragen, weil ich oft nicht weiss, wenn ich jemandem sehe, ob er dann dem zugeneigt ist oder ob er irgendwie so ein Beef am Laufen haben. Am Ende löst du irgendwie den nächsten East Coast-West Coast-Konflikt aus und merkst du so, wow, Leute, ich bin nur dummer Deutscher. Ich hatte einen geilen Job in New York und das sagt so, was fucking in New York alles passiert. Ich war, mein Job war es, es hat ein neues Lokal aufgemacht und die haben mich bezahlt und mehrere andere, einfach draußen zu sitzen und zu essen. Also ich habe pro Stunde zehn Dollar bekommen, ganzes Essen und Getränke umsonst, ja. Und dann na na, es heisst Window-Modeling, aber das hat nichts mit Modeling zu tun. Und das Geile war halt irgendwie, ich saß da zwei Stunden und am Ende kommt so jemand rum und gibt mir so einen Briefumschlag, und dann habe ich gesehen, dieser Typ hat alle im Restaurant einen Briefumschlag gegeben. Ach du Scheiße. Ja. Ach so, da hält die Leute, die denken, da ist viel los, oder was? Genau, so dass sie mehr Publikum ein... Und das Geile war, ich hatte zwei Freunde aus Deutschland, die mit mich besuchen gekommen sind und ich so, komm, lass uns da hingehen, ja. Und ich so, es geht auf mich. Und ich hab pro Person, den ich mitbekommen hab, nochmal fünf Euro für mich bekommen. Aber das ist seltsam, wenn alle in dem Laden einen Umschlag bekommen haben, hat er vielleicht zu viele Leute da hingesetzt, weil dann, wenn der Laden voll ist.
Ja, und das ist halt einfach Geldwäsche, dass sie halt einfach immer so tun müssen, als wäre viel los, weil die dadurch halt viel Geld waschen, aber eigentlich mehr dafür ausgeben wollen.
Stimmt, das kann auch sein.
Und dann hast du gedacht, okay, lieber Hammersworth, Mariusiris, ab nach Deutschland.
Doch lieber zu Aldi.
Ich will doch lieber eine Lauterbach kennenlernen.
Nee, ich hatte ja wirklich diese, diese, äh, nee, ich war dann auch, ich hatte ja einen Freund gehabt, der wirklich tatsächlich mit der Nanny abgehauen ist. So wirklich krass Klischee. Überhaupt nicht schlimm. Ist das Klischee, mit der Nanny abzauern? Ja, das ist doch voll das L.A. Klischee. Ah ja, okay, sorry, aber jetzt bin ich nicht so in L.A. Klischees drin. Nee, aber es war auch ... Das war auch keine richtige Beziehung. Ich habe auch nur mit ihm zusammen gewohnt, weil ich dadurch mein Apartment, also es war so everybody, just like, auf jeden Fall, also es war auch wirklich, ich habe auch schon vorher Schluss gemacht, es war nicht so krass, wie es sich anhört, es hört sich nur cool an. Und dann habe ich aber gedacht so, Alter, das ist doch mein Gedankengang, hm, ich brauche irgendwie noch einen Job, werde ich auch Nanny, ja, und hab dann, aber, aber ich hab dann so wirklich, ich hab mir so ein Resume zusammengewurschtelt, so vom Babysitten damals, und hab tatsächlich, hab ich für, kennt ihr, Taschen, also Taschen, ja, ist die lustige, die weinen, glaube ich, den Verlag, ne? Ich meine den Verlag, Taschen. Ja, das kenne ich. Wie heißt der mein Vornamen? Ich habe vergessen. Auf jeden Fall hat der zwei… der wohnt in L.A. Ja, der hat die abgefahrensten Häuser da. In seinem UFO wohnt der doch da. Genau. Ja, und da habe ich für einen Monat auf seine Kinder aufgepasst. In diesem UFO-Gebäude? In diesem UFO-Bau. What the hell, das ist die krasseste Designerbude der Welt einfach. Ja, das ist echt krass. Ach komm schon. Du hast in einem UFO gearbeitet? Ja, aber das Geile ist, ich hab die Kinder so … Ja, das ist so ein Riesendesignergebäude einfach am Rande in so einer Klippe. Die ist auch auf Google Maps so als so. Ja, das ist einfach so eine der Major-Designwohnungen der Welt. Es gibt das Eames-Haus und die Wohnung von dem Taschentypen. Das Geile war, ich war so … ich hab die Kinder so gehasst. Ich war so schlecht, ich konnte diesen Job nicht machen, so überhaupt nicht. Und ich hab so einmal aus Versehen das Kind so geschubst. Aus dem Ufo raus, Klippe runter, ist leider tot. Und es ist so hingefallen, ich so fuck, überall Kamera, shit. Google Maps, der Satellit, so. Und das Geile, ich hatte halt so ein Cabrio Chrysler Auto gehabt, ja, aber das war das krasseste, abgefuckteste, schlimmste Auto, was du dir jemals vorstellen kannst, ja.
Ich musste, wenn ich es ausschalte, musste ich, I had to open the hood, so den Motorhaube auch machen, um die Batterie zu disconnect.
Ich musste die Batterie ausschalten, jedes Mal so, weil wenn ich es nur so ausmache und gehe und zehn Minuten später romme, kann ich es nicht wieder anmachen. So und es war so ein ganz anderer Rhythmus, also es waren so teilweise Phasen, wo ich es halt irgendwie zwei Minuten, also so eine halbe Stunde ausschalten konnte, dann war es halt anders.
Es war schwer zu erklären und manchmal konnte ich es auch so länger ausschalten konnte, dann war es halt anders. Es war schwer zu erklären. Und manchmal konnte ich es auch so länger ausschalten. Hinten gab es kein Fenster.
Es war, glaube ich, das Auto, was man am wenigsten vor dem Haus erwartet.
Oh, das ist richtig. Ich habe auch selber drauf graffitied, habe so geschrieben, so
I'm killing my car und Detroit Homegirl.
Und ja, da waren Ameisen drin, also es war ein richtiges, ein bisschen ähnlich. Also, warte mal, und es wurde einmal sogar von den Bullen abgestoppt und die so, Ma'am, could you turn off your car? Und ich so, ah, excuse me, sir, but if I turn it off, I can't turn it back on. Ja, das hören wir an dauernd. Und dann, explain. Die fliehen sonst alle. Aber ich fand's irgendwie cool, weil das war so, ein Auto war so lebendig und ich hab, ich musste am Anfang so immer ganz, ganz oft, totally, ich musste ganz oft, wie heisst das, Starthilfe. Ja. Und ich fand das echt cool, weil ich voll viele Leute kennengelernt habe. Weil die die Starthilfe geben müssen. Ja, ich wusste auch in welchem Bezirk, man hat echt länger warten muss. Ist es nicht so gefährlich als Frau in L.A. Starthilfe? Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich habe so Dates gekriegt. Die Starthilfe, das machen wir vielleicht falsch. Ich habe ein sehr gut funktionierendes Auto. Das ist mein Problem. Ja, das ist das Problem in Deutschland, wir haben einfach fucking gute Autos. Gute Autos, ja. Wir haben BMWs, wir haben ... Bessere Autos dafür, keine Liebe. Aber es war immer so, schaffe ich es zum Casting oder nicht? Es bleibt offen. Im Cliffhanger, das ganze Leben ist ein Cliffhanger. Aber was ich so krass finde in L.A., dass einfach alle Leute die ganze Zeit nur Leute, glaube ich, auf ihrem Weg missbrauchen, um halt den nächsten Audition-Job oder so zu bekommen, um durchs Casting zu fahren. Das ist doch echt krass. Ja, ich glaube, das war auch so ein Ding, warum ich irgendwann mal gedacht habe, so, ich will hier... Das ist schon hart. Das ist schon, ja, ich war dann irgendwie im dritten, also viermal im Monat irgendwie im selben Raum, alle sahen genauso aus wie ich und es geht um eine Zeile, die man irgendwie in einer Serie... Weisst du, und dann war es so, cool und wäre das auf jeden Fall Hut ab für die Leute, die das machen, so, aber ich habe mir gedacht, ich schmeisse irgendwie so mein Leben so ein bisschen hin, so, weil dann wäre ja mein, wenn ich es endlich schaffe, eine Zeile zu bekommen, das wäre nicht zu cool. Es tut mir gerade echt ein bisschen leid, dass du im Podcast-UFO gelandet bist. Ich schäme mich für unseren Podcast, dass du jemanden, der so hohe Möglichkeiten hatte, so viele Chancen am Leben und jetzt so, ich habe das alles hingeschmissen und jetzt von dir im Podcast-UFO. Jetzt ist sie im Podcast-UFO. Sie ist vom Taschen-UFO ins Podcast-UFO gelandet. Das ist der Absturz, genau. The downward spiral. Der grösste Absturz, den man sich überhaupt vorstellen kann.
Alter, aber du hast echt ein krasses Leben da geführt. Das ist schon hart. Also alle Anekdoten, die man jetzt erzählt, wirken einfach lächerlich. Ich zocke halt viel über The Warcraft so, also ich weiß, ich habe was interessiert. Ich habe gestern auf Netflix eine Doku gesehen über Wale. und zwar ... Ja ... Ich habe letztens eine geile Doku gesehen von, ah, das habe ich, von Werner Herzog. Ja. Und da fand ich, da konnte man so deutsche Kultur und amerikanische Kultur so richtig geil ... Okay, auf jeden Fall interviewt er so einen Typen, es ging um die Todesstrafe in Texas, ja, habt ihr den vielleicht gesehen?
Nee.
Und Werner Herzog steht so hinter der Kamera, man hört so nur seine Stimme und vorne ist halt so ein Typ in Texas, so ein junger, lebendiger Mann, ja, und, ähm, lebendig, war nicht tot, war lebend, das ist sehr wichtig. Und wenn er halt so gross ist, so, so tell me, when did you read about your friends getting murdered?
Und der Typ sagt so, well, you know, I didn't read it because I can't read, but my friends told me and it's like, oh fuck. And then Werner Herzog goes, what is written on your arm? What is that? And he goes, yeah, that's a tattoo. it's from my girl, I love her, her name is Trisha.
So Riesentattoo so am Arm. Und dann sagt Werner Herzog, so voll deutsch, but it is a tattoo, it is permanent. What happens if you don't love Trisha anymore? Und er sagt so, well, I guess I'll write Trisha sucks. Aber war das Interview, hat er ja gerade auf diesem elektrischen Stuhl gesessen? Das habe ich mir gerade vorgestellt, während er des Interviews mit der Werner Herzog auf so einem elektrischen Stuhl zu sitzen ist auch bestimmt ein ganz geiles. Warum elektrische, warum? Warte Frage, er hat das Setup falsch verstanden, seine Freunde wurden, sind gestorben, ne? Ja. Ich dachte, ich dachte die ganze Zeit, dass Werner Herzizel quasi das letzte Gespräch mit diesem Mann führt, bevor er stirbt. So bevor er stirbt.
Dann ist er nicht ein bisschen traurig, so. Do you agree with the interview, Tuju, wo Werner Heizel...
Oh, er gar nicht, er gar nicht.
Wäre auch nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, so würde ich auch gerne sterben, auf dem elektrischen Stuhl, während man von Werner Heizel...
Ne, Podcast!
Hören auch nochmal so ein paar Techniken raus, ne, Callback, die Technik, dass man irgendwas von vorher in seinem Session erzählt hat, nochmal zurück, damit die Leute sich daran erinnern und einen schlechten, einfachen Lacher draus ziehen kann. Was gibt's noch für so einfache Techniken, Leute? Also dann gibt's ja Punchline, dann gibt's Buildup, dann gibt's Throwaway. Nur zurück zu Punchline. Wie genau funktioniert Anonym. Die Deutschen sind, wir haben alles gelernt, die Punchline. Wir haben gelernt, aber die Punchline, das ist noch, glaube ich, ein Problem, was gerade in diesem Podcast fehlt. Ja, unsere Gags sind immer sehr gut, bis dann die Punchline kommt. Dann ist immer ... Unsere Setups sind also abgeschmeckt, würde ich sagen. Man sagt, eine Frau kommt zum Arzt, aber dann fehlt die Punchline. Okay, Build-Up, wie funktioniert Build-Up? Ja, etwas aufbauen, dass man sagt, so ... Gott, Gott, mir fällt jetzt gar nichts ein, aber so, es war...
Das ist, glaube ich, schlecht im Improv, wenn einem nichts eintritt.
Ich habe ja nicht bis alle vier gemacht. Ich habe ja nur drei UCB-Sachen gemacht.
Was unterschaltet ein Level-4-UCBler von einem Level-3-UCBler?
Was ist der Unterschied?
400 Dollar.
Okay. Was ich auch gelesen habe, wenn man Improv macht, wir machen oft, machen wir Leute nach dann plötzlich. Ich habe es zum Beispiel bei Angela Merkel nachgemacht und sehr schlecht natürlich. Zeig mal. Ne, möchte ich jetzt nicht machen, möchte ich nie wieder machen. Aber dann hat Florentin natürlich direkt darüber gelacht, wie schlecht diese Angela Merkel Imitation war, Impression war. Und in dem Buch, was ich jetzt gelesen habe, wo man lernt, wie man Improv macht, stand ja direkt drin, dass man niemals quasi auflösen soll, die Illusion auflösen soll. Also man darf nie im Leben sagen, okay, das klang jetzt aber eher wie ein Werner Herzog als wie ein Angela Merkel. Das sollte man das halt, also eine Oberregel, dass man nie die Illusion zerstören soll. Also an der Stelle nochmal vielen Dank für den grossen Ablauf. Aber man sollte auch gegenseitig sich nicht umbringen, weil ... Tote Menschen sind nicht lustig. Nee, aber wenn man zum Beispiel, das kann man halt, wenn du zum Beispiel deinen Kollegen einfach nicht mal ... findest deine Ideen schlecht, kannst du mitten in der Szene ja einfach nur eine pretend gun rausschmeissen und er muss ja yes and, er muss ja dann sterben. Ja, aber ich bin Zombie. Ist das ein grosses Problem? Nee, aber ich hab's ganz oft gemacht. Also es ist wie in dem The Office-Bit, wo irgendwie Michael immer zum Improv geht und egal welche Szene ist, er spielt immer den, den, den, den, den sich an keine Regeln haltenden Undercover-Corp, der alle immer erschießt sofort. Egal welche Szene, wir sind ein romantisches Dinner und er kommt bricht so zur Tür rein und schießt alle, egal was die Szene ist. Und alle mussten sterben spielen. Ja, genau, alle mussten immer so, oh Gott, die sind toll. So stelle ich es mir auch vor, dass ein grosses Problem ist, dass Leute immer, Leute erschiessen alle, egal was die Szene ist. Und alle mussten sterben spielen. Ja genau, alle müssen immer so, oh, warte ich schon wieder, fuck you.
So stelle ich es mir auch vor, dass ein grosses Problem ist, dass Leute immer, Leute erschießen, einfach egal welche Situation.
Ja, ja, auch ganz gut.
Können wir jetzt ein Improv-Stück machen?
Nein, glaube ich nicht.
Jetzt in diesem Moment?
Wie würde man das jetzt machen?
Ohne dass es gewollt, dass es so gewollt wirkt und so aus dem Nichts kommt.
Wir wollen jetzt aus dem Nichts und gewollt ein Improv-Stück machen, ohne dass es genau so wirkt und so aus dem Nichts kommt. Wir wollen es aus dem Nichts und gewollten Impro-Stück machen, ohne dass es genau so wirkt.
Mach du mal nochmal deine Merke. Das leiseste Impro der Welt. Es ist mega lustig, aber wir machen es halt nur mit Gesichtern.
Wir machen es. Das war ein Impro-Stück, wie man in die falsche Seite des Mikros spricht.
Ja, richtig gut war die Promisse. Nicht so gut funktioniert. Ist auch schwierig, ne? Naja. Aber es gibt ja ... Wie viele Schaus habt ihr gesehen? Zwei? Also einmal Gentrify gesehen und einmal Ask Hat. Wir waren nur eine Woche da. Weil es gibt so viele verschiedene Arten auch anzufangen. Weil es gibt ja nicht immer diese Regel, dass man sagt, okay, der Berühmte macht einen Monolog, sondern es gibt Millionen von verschiedenen verschiedenen. Ich habe einmal gesehen, das war ganz cool, da haben die ein paar, jeder, der wollte, konnte sein Handy abgeben und da war so ein DJ hinten, der hat einfach nur reingesteckt und hat Lieder durchgegangen von verschiedenen, von was die so hatten als Playback und einfach eins rausgesucht, Musik hat angefangen und sie haben daraus eine Szene gespielt. Von dieser, von dieser, also sozusagen war die Musik das erste Wort. Okay, weil das Suggestion ist dann so wie eine Art Soundtrack für die Szene, die gerade läuft. Genau, ja, ja. Und dann war es so, zum Beispiel war ein romantisches, romantisches Lied und sofort gegen zwei Männer auf die Bühne und einer spielt, wir sind in Röverbieren, in so einem Flösslein und so und in Frankreich. Wenn du Dinge verniedlichen willst, machst du immer ein Line dahinter. Schifflein, Flusslein. Punchline. Au! Sehr gut. War das der beste Gag? Ich glaub nicht. Nee, wir sind total baff irgendwie, dass du so krasse Storys raushaust. Normalerweise erlebst Stefan immer die krassen Sachen irgendwie. Normalerweise sieht er auch nicht zufällig in Miley Cyrus und Leap in Hammersburg. Erzähl doch noch mal deine Ananas-Story, die fand ich richtig geil. Ja, crazy Geschichte. Die ist aber richtig gut. Als wir zum Comedy-Club gegangen sind, ungefähr 20 Minuten glaube ich, und auf dem Weg dahin sehe ich plötzlich einen Krankenwagen und ein Mann, ich würde sagen, könnte ein Obdachloser gewesen sein, liegt auf dem Boden, mit dem Rücken auf dem Boden, die beiden Hände so nach hinten ausgestreckt, so als würde er da wirklich vom Himmel gefallen sein. Und dann sind Leute um ihn herum und wiederbeleben ihn. Das ist ziemlich furchtbar alles. Aber dann kommt der lustige Teil der Geschichte, wo ich finde ... Gut, dass du es noch mal ... Ich habe den lustigen Podcast gerade gehört. Ja, ich würde euch bitten, dieses Rätsel zu lösen. Ich habe es nicht geschafft. In ungefähr drei Meter Entfernung lag ein weisser Plastikbeutel mit Ananas. Mit einer Ananas? Nee, mit so einem Haufen bereits geschnittener Ananas. Diese gelben Stückchen. Der Beutel mit Ananas. Mit einer Ananas? Nee, mit mehreren, so einem Haufen geschnittener, bereits geschnittener Ananas, diese gelben Stückchen. Der Beutel war randvoll mit diesem Stückchen Ananas und es gab so eine kleine Spur, die dahin führte, zu dem Beutel. Spur von was? Von Ananas-Flüssigkeit. Ungefähr drei Meter Abstand. Ich würde es den Ananas-Mord nennen, jetzt schon, ohne zu wissen, ob der gestorben ist, ohne zu wissen, was da passiert ist vorher, aber es klingt ganz geil. Ich frag mich, was da passiert ist. Also angenommen, er hätte die Tüte Ananas in der Hand gehabt und wäre umgefallen, dann läge sie näher an ihm. Läge sie näher an ihm. Ein Autounfall, dann wäre das Auto noch da wahrscheinlich. Ja, oder und die Ananas halt verteilt will. Ja, genau. Es sieht so aus, als hätte er... Oder jemand ist vorbeigefahren mit der Ananas-Tüte und hat den so ... und dann hat sie losgelassen und deswegen ist es a trail. Ja, also ich glaube, es muss folgendermaßen gewesen sein. Oder in New York eher so rum. Ich glaube, er war ein bisschen crazy, hat dann die Ananas-Tüte wie so ein Bowling oder wie so ein Botcher, wie so Buhlen, wenn du halt so eine Kugel wirfst. Dann hat er, glaube ich, einfach so den Beutel weggeworfen und so sah das nämlich aus. Dann ist der gerutscht und dann liegen geblieben und er ist einfach so schlaganfallmäßig. Genau, also im Umfallen hat er den Beutel geworfen. Genau, er ist aber umgefallen und lag dann so auf dem Boden. Ja, aber finde ich gut, weiss ich nicht, aber warum hat er, die Vorgeschichte ist ja vielleicht, warum hat der so viel Ananas dabei? Und das liegt daran, das ist ja so was man hört, wenn man nicht ganz viel Ananas isst, schmeckt das Sperma besser. Oh Gott, das kam ganz komisch raus, aber ist das nicht, habt ihr das nicht gelesen? Ja doch, kann ich auch nicht. Das ist doch so ein Ding, ja? Schmeckt es dann nach Ananas ein bisschen? Also schmeckt, also schmeckt Schmeckt ... Schüss oder sowas? Nee, also was heisst denn besser?
Ich denke, das klang auch gerade so als ... Also, der Sohn kennt mich gerade da.
Nein, wann schmeckt Schmermer vielleicht denn besser?
Ich kenne die Theorie auch, aber ich weiss nicht genau, was besser ... Also, das habe
ich auch schon gehört.
Also, sagen wir mal hier in diesem Fiasko, mit diesem Ananas-Mord ist es so, dass er ...
Der Ananas-Fiasko.
Okay, dass er eine, er hat eine Frau und ein Kind, ja, Kind heisst Dorothee, ja, und
Vielen Dank. Dieser Ananas-Mord ist es so, dass er … Der Ananas-Fiasc. Okay, dass er eine … er hat eine Frau und ein Kind, ja? Kind heisst Dorothee, ja? Und Dorothee ist irgendwie aus Versehen durch sein Handy gegangen, weil sie das Passwort gefunden, rausgefunden hat, so ganz aus Versehen hat es Dorothee gefunden. Und daraufhin hat die Mutter das gesehen und hat gesehen, dass ihr Mann sich betrügt. Ich kenne sie ein bisschen wie so eine Anwältin, die versucht, eine... Ja, also, das könnte alles so gelaufen sein, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, 100% sicher. Du kriegst wie eine Anwältin, die die Akten nicht gelesen hat. Und dann hat die Tochter das Messer, die Pistole, den Ananasbeutel, genau. Und die auch aus dem Raum einfach nimmt. Dann hat sie die Vorhänge genommen. Und sie hatte so ein langes schwarzes Kleid an. Und so eine weisse Perücke. Okay, also die Frau findet heraus, dass sie betrogen wird. Findet heraus, dass betrogen wird. Und die lesen auch, die liest die ganzen SMS und da drin steht, so dass er sagt, so heute Abend ess ich ganz viel Ananas, so dass du manchmal essen kannst. Und das kriegt sie mit, klaut die Tüte, fährt vorbei und haut ihn damit ab. Okay, das ist nicht schlecht. Was wäre jetzt? Reicht das denn zum Tod, einen Beutel Ananas über den Kopf bekommen? Er ist ja nicht gestorben. Er ist nicht gestorben, er ist nicht gestorben, er muss nur wiederbelebt werden. Oder Ananasallergie. Wobei ich mich dann frage, wenn man davon ausgehen könnte, dass man eine Ananasallergie hat, hat man vielleicht schon mal in seinem Leben vorher was von gemerkt, warum man dann so viel Ananas gehabt. Vielleicht wusste er nicht, dass er eine Ananasallergie hat. Ich denke, das weiss man. Und dann auf einmal weiss man. Man hat das im Gefühl, man hat das im Schwer, dass man keine Ananas macht. Ananas? Nein, danke. Ja. Falls ihr Ideen habt, Informationen habt, vielleicht sogar der Mann seid, der jetzt wieder endlich rekurriert im Krankenhaus liegt und die Ananas-Geschichte lösen könnte, schreibt uns unter www.podcast-ofo.fail. Punkt fail? podcastus ofo. Ofo. Punkt. Punkt. Fail. Punkt fail. Punkt fail? Podcast minus ofo.fail. Was ist deine Lieblings-Internetseite? Einfach als rausgehe, aber die Leute, wenn die den Podcast gehört haben und sagen, geil, fand ich gut, hat mir Spaß gemacht, was kann ich als nächstes anschauen, was ist der next step, the next level? Facebook. Facebook, okay, also schaut doch mal auf facebook.com vorbei. Ein kleiner Insider-Tipp, wenn ihr das noch nicht gesehen habt, f-a-c-e-book.com. Punkt com oder Punkt was? Ich glaube, es ist com. Schaut einfach mal, was eure URL-Zeile draus macht, ne, einfach mal ein bisschen Improv. Yes and gilt auch für die URL-Einste. Gilt auch für das URL-Eingeben. Nun gut, das war Katja Gerz. Katjana, Müsst du über Katja oder Katjana genannt werden? Oder Gerzi. Gerzi. Gerzi. Ich hätte meinen Nignamen. Äh, ne, den sage ich jetzt nicht, weil der ganz schlimm ist. Doch, sag ihn. Die Outromusik läuft schon, ne, also es ist kaum ein bisschen rein. Immer lauter vor allem auch, unangenehm läuft. Okay, vielen Dank, dass ihr zugebracht habt. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Bis dann, was wird, und wir heben ab.